opération massive merci madame la parole
est à monsieur bernard perrut monsieur
le premier ministre
quatre de vos ministres agriculture
environnement santé économie s'apprête à
signer un arrêté très coercitives pour
nos agriculteurs et leurs productions
le voici car il existe bien
contrairement ce que le ministre
l'agriculture a répondu la semaine
dernière s'il faut bien sûr des règles
d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires votre volonté d'élargir
le périmètre des zones de non traitement
n'est pas sans conséquences graves
oui très grave pour nos cultures et nos
territoires ruraux
de telles mesures entraîneront
inévitablement en retrait potentiel de
plusieurs millions d'hectares un recul
important de la production alimentaire
française
la suppression de milliers d'emplois
agricoles
la perte de plusieurs milliards d'euros
par an de chiffre d'affaires des
distorsions de concurrence accrue avec
les producteurs européens
si toutes les productions sont concernés
la situation préoccupante très
préoccupante pour nos vignobles
car la délimitation de zones interdites
de traitement autour des lieux de vie
conduire à un arrachage des plantations
à proximité des habitations
car sans traitements contre les maladies
elles ne pourront survivre est toute
nouvelle construction mes chers
collègues fera chaque jour rupture et la
vigne sur notre territoire
ce sera la remise en cause l'équilibré
que les mythes des petites exploitations
la transformation des villages et des
paysages atout essentiel pour le
tourisme
monsieur le premier ministre vous
connaissez le sens des responsabilités
l'engagement les pratiques des
agriculteurs en faveur de
l'environnement et pour préserver les
populations et leur santé alors pourquoi
engager vous une telle surenchère
réglementaire loin du besoin de
simplification et d'allègement des
contraintes
allez vous écouter oui allez vous
écoutez les agriculteurs leur faire
confiance
respectez leur travail et les rassurer
cet après midi nous devons nous battre
pour produire en france
consommer français parole et jean marie
le guen
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement si monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
tout d'abord j'ai soufflé s'est désolé
folle il vous plaît monsieur le député
bernard perrut vous savez que le
gouvernement dans la nécessité de
réécrire effectivement un arrêté puisque
le précédent a été cassée par le conseil
d'état pour à défaut et un vice de forme
d'un gouvernement en 2006 que vous
connaissiez bien
bref nous voulons instituer une nouvelle
méthode de travail permettant de
concerter les représentants agricoles
dans une démarche interministérielle qui
prennent en charge
évidemment les différents points de vue
cela se fera sous la responsabilité du
préfet beach conformément au souhait du
premier ministre
le comité de rénovation des normes en
agriculture s'est réuni à plusieurs
reprises et dernièrement encore les
consultations d'ensemble ont eu lieu
et je peux vous dire que le projet qui
sera transmis à la commission européenne
sera conforme à la ligne constante qui
sous-tend attraction depuis 2012
nous devons éviter c'était votre souci
monsieur le député de tout sur
transposition du droit européen
sans évidemment reculer vous ne l'avez
pas proposé sur les dispositions
actuellement en vigueur du devons faire
preuve de pragmatisme
s'agissant de l'environnement et de la
santé les personnes et aussi de réalisme
ça concernant l'activité des
agriculteurs donc l'arrêté était
nécessaire il n'a qu'une seul objectif
c'est de répondre à ces deux objectifs
tous les acteurs doivent être
responsabilité car vous le savez sont
concernés bien sûr les agriculteurs dans
leur production mais aussi les ouvriers
agricoles et l'ensemble des riverains
des parcelles agricoles par les
conséquences sanitaires que cela peut
avoir et je connais votre souci de l'
équilibre entre ces deux termes
et donc je pense que vous aurez
satisfaction
mais